combining bingo with exercise is a good
workout for mind and body a great way to
manage the realities of Aging for the
older residents of San Rafael California
like Gretchen and Jim who's nearly 89.
and how has it been getting there
hectic
this is the first time I've ever
addressed it but I think my sex life
could be improved
other than that my life is a Bowl of
Cherries if I knew science could develop
something where I could keep my memory
and physical ability till the day I died
I'd be happy with that one yeah yeah
right now science can't offer that but
easy to bounce to healthy ages like
Gretchen and Jim the inspiration for
What's Happening Here in California a
boom in anti-aging research a few things
better embody the pursuit of Eternal
youth than Californian Beach culture you
only have to look around you to see the
ravages at time affect us all
differently some people live healthy
lives but Die Young others go on well
beyond their 90s and it's that fact
that's convinced scientists aging is
something we can prevent
Steve holdath pioneered a way of
measuring this difference so why do you
need a clock that can measure my
biological Edge people of the same
chronologic age or calendar age have a
different biologic aging rates
like an hourglass in every cell hovath's
clock tells us how different parts of
this age in different ways take the
immune system it weakens and with it our
ability to fight off infection low-grade
inflammation increases raising the risk
of things like heart disease and
dementia and our brain function declines
as do our senses like eyesight and
hearing and as early as 50 bones get
thinner and weaker muscle mass is lost
and it's harder to rebuild but is all
this inevitable eating is not the same
as rust accumulating on a car it's not
just breakdown but rather there are
processes that can be manipulated you
can tweak it in certain ways I interpret
aging as a software error could that
Insight explain why the home of big Tech
is fascinated with aging here in Silicon
Valley anti-aging research is very much
the New Frontier Google has invested in
it but things really changed earlier
this year when Bezos the Amazon founder
put money into Altos Labs which launched
with three billion dollars of funding
the largest in biotech history
Altos is too new to have announced any
potential treatments but other Bay Area
biotechs are forging ahead each of these
dots here is a molecular entity like a
protein or a small molecule a metabolite
that circulates in your blood bio age is
using big data to try and unravel the
mysteries of Aging rather than peering
into Petri dishes or looking at lab
animals this biotech company is taking a
very different approach to trying to
find human specific drivers of aging and
they're doing that by using computer
power to sit through vast databases of
biological samples to try and find
common factors among people who live
very long healthy lives compared to
those who die much younger and they're
already finding some promising targets
so there's a protein called apollon that
circulates in your blood and we saw that
people middle-aged people
with higher levels of apron in their
blood were living longer with better
muscle function and better cognitive
function as they aged so we gave this
drug to really old mice and we showed
that it can improve their muscle
function it helped them run better in
their wheels it increased their muscle
size it improved their grip strength the
human trial is now underway to see
whether their drug Works in older people
as well as it does in mice
here at the buck Institute in the Hills
above Silicon Valley they're looking
directly at human cells to understand
how they age these are normal
feel yourself
the right here we're looking at looking
at senescent cells and these senescent
cells are the ones we find at in higher
numbers in aging tissues correct
in a lab upstairs they're studying
senescence cells in tiny clumps of human
brain tissue some from young healthy
brains others from older people and
those suffering conditions like dementia
so what's the end game
Eternal youth says Campisi has never
been her Focus promise
has increased longevity increased
lifespan
has that been achieved no
it has hardly even been achieved in a
mouse to be honest the real benefit is
going to be what we call Health spam
meaning
to live healthier and without
some of the debilitating diseases
of Aging you could see silicon Valley's
pursuit of Aging as the Uber wealthy's
way of looking to hack their own
mortality or is it a much needed boost
for a long neglected field of science
that will ensure Millions enjoy a
healthier old age and save Society
trillions treating the diseases that
come with it
Tom Clark Sky News San Francisco